he can access the roof and regain his
freedom started so perfunctory in just
like basic beat reporting and now we're
in the realm of
poetry
s guys do you ever feel like money is
just flying out of your account and you
have no idea where it's going well look
we know it's all those subscriptions so
we use rocket money to help us find out
what subscriptions were actually
spending money on which ones we're using
which ones were not it was eye openening
and look we had them cancel the ones
that we didn't want anymore stop wasting
money you don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions go to Rocket money.com DPT
that's rocketman.com
DPT rocket
money.com DPT hey Tes welcome to another
episode of people Town population yeah
population
Casher Casher thei third are you mosha
Casher the third I this well I might be
mosha Casher I thir appearance on dumb
people hey now you've been here multiple
times because you're just one of friend
of the show friend of the friend of ours
friend of ours one of the fastest
funniest best people we know you and
someone I love seeing when we're out I
The Comedy Store we just stood among
many people and had a beautiful
conversation recently one night and it
was so wonderful when you came I was
when you came did our show right I think
yeah it was so good you were we were
talking about how you were like an
anti-id vaccine activist yeah it's so
weird own so much of my own research
research well because I the research I
want to share it yeah well you were on
stage screaming about it and it was very
research I mean I heard something
sometime and it came my way uh so the
world's getting Dumber thank God uh and
oh yeah that's good for you H it's great
for us bad booming for the world find of
it leveled off it's bad for the it's
like we like the guys at the casino that
bet the don't pass line that bet people
people to Lose It Craft you're shorting
the the world you're Humanity on life
that's the real big this is The Big
Short right here so this is the big dumb
so our awesome fans send us stories and
I don't know if this we did this the
last time you were on but now each of us
get to do a story that we then present
to you last time I think it was all Dan
Dan's got the first one should we jump
into one and then we'll get into What mo
got going on also I forgot to take off
my Band-Aids that I realized and it is
possibly
probably could have done my own dumb
story people are going to watch this and
be like the [__] with Daniel's he
tried to stop a saw something you're not
far off what did you you do what did you
do Dan so I was using a Julian vegetable
cutting machine yes taking some things
and your thumb went right into the
thing the like uh it broke off like the
hand like where it snaps in and you put
it over the vegetable you go yep snapped
off mhm so then I was like oh I I got to
put this back on so I got to put it back
on but what I in between me saying I got
to put this back on and then trying to
put it back on I should have lowered the
razor blade and flushed it you know so
that it doesn't Elevate out and so I'm
holding it trying to put the thing back
on both thumbs and then it snaps off
again while I'm doing it and as it snaps
off I go like this you Julian yourself
you Julian fing that's called a self
Julian it's called a self it's called
autoerotic Julian called a Julian Len
that's a Julian
Mar there was a portion when I was like
David kerine of Julian of this
experience where I was like
uh one thumb is [__] right two thumbs is
comedy I can't text two thumbs is
hilarious who's got two [__] up thumbs
and trying to apply pressure to both
thumbs at the same time to get them to
stop bleeding holding them like over my
head and I'm like this is a [__]
you've devolved actually you're no
all of the SK Thum it is the most
annoying thing in my life right now
those are hitchhiking thumbs how dare
every time you my butt fly jeans every
single one of them and you only do
buttonfly Levi's buttonfly 501 you know
this about me we all know brought me up
last time we did our show this guy is
the king of the buttonfly and he's got
great thumbs who's got two th [__] and
cut thumbs two [__] well speaking of
[__] how going for you it's harder it's
harder I bet you have to do it kind of
more otter style more classic otter
eating an oyster style I'm Lobster style
I'm like a dolphin trying to hold a Cofe
up
like d okay here we go sent in by ASA
Finance at Dragon
ilm thank you Florida man this is the
headline Florida man arrested obviously
MH after locking him himself into Little
Caesars that he burglarized
yep do intentional or not intentional
blocking him you mean this is like an
all the
breiz piz dum dum dream bigger dream
bigger right you know why Little Caesars
that's a great point because you had
Little Caesars recently I'm not saying
it's gross I'm saying it's the cheapest
of all foods right how much money could
be in the cash reg or even on a good
night $9.99 but he's like the money is
hot and ready I don't care about the
quality or size B look the denomination
of the bill is not important to me and
what do you always say like lock
yourself in the story you wish to be in
sure like if you're if you are you're
right if you are going to break into
somewhere ites risk allar do you want to
say it was a Little Caesars do you think
he said at two locking door guys this is
fun that's a knife in the back of this
guy's attempt I'll say this about it I
can't believe Little Caesars has locks
at all you know what I mean for what
they just be like look if you guys want
it just ready you take it take it a
Florida man dressed only in boxer shorts
did he say I locked it locked it yes
there you go okay there you go a Florida
man
dressed just I don't I'm so sorry to
interrupt but I do I do a crazy little
Caesar impression let's hear it well I
don't want to like kind of blow we we
might end the show on it okay you do it
now and that'll probably I think I'm
fine with that can I plug the book or
just I'll just do the impression the
book
later pizza
pizza that is so good you excellent I'm
hung does anybody have Goosebumps I have
Goosebumps my my mouth is
watering Florida man dressed only in
boxer shorts and socks was arrested
after breaking into a Little Caesars and
making his way through the drive-thru
window oh so he climbed in yes and then
locked the window early Saturday morning
Chad Korn Chad corn Chad corn I love I
love Chad corn that's my favorite
popcorn snack you know spelled k r n I
wish I me that's how he signs it but
it's a legal C Chad Chad Korn is the
Little Caesars of
names Chad corn when I grew up in Iowa
and that was what we a treat we had
every
Halloween We Gather on the Chad scary St
early Saturday morning Chad he literally
a child of the Corn mhm Chad Korn of
Milton Florida decided to check the door
to the Little Caesars on Navy Boulevard
oh he found the door unlocked so he went
through
the drive oh I think drivethru window
might up being the way he gets out yes
sure he found the door unlocked the
burglar then decided he had the skills
necessary to pull pull off a daring midm
morning Heist how many times did he
punch the cash register to see if it
would open up mid morning yelled at it
yeah you open up why is Little Caesar's
open midm morning why it's not go ahead
motion you the door was unlock going to
be good I mean I can't even believe we
moved past it yeah he punches the cash
register and says the crust is stuff why
not the
register according to deputies K opened
the door and began to gather the goods
first it was a bottle of water then two
he couldn't bring himself to pass by a
wrapped brownie on the counter so he
grabbed it as well according are they
good are those Little Caesar's brownies
brownies good good the person who wrote
this by the way began and ented this
ended this sentence with according to
deputies okay so according to deputies
according to deputies yada y yada ACC
according to deputies
Deputy say k made his way through the
store and notices an employees apron he
placed the apron around his waist to
complete his outfit don't clock in I
will say this corn makes its way through
everyone know Ls up going out the back
fully
intact I love that he wanted an apron
but this guy is not I would say a master
criminal he two bottles of water and a
brownie so far and an apron so far okay
right sorry I mean an apron is like the
a certain upgrade to what he's wearing
boxers and socks yes I agree also you
know I don't and even though it's
Florida to me the socks are wet yeah wet
annoying they started white and they're
brown
SW couldn't bring himself to go past the
brownie he grabbed that he already had
the water uh on his way through the
story he notice the apron he put that
around his waist to complete his outfit
there's something about boxer shorts
tube socks and a corporate inspired
apron that must have empowered the
burglar well we got a real Rider on our
hands according to
with his collection of stolen items he
makes his way to the door this is where
the poorly planned Escapade begins to
unravel you see the door from which he
had just entered was now locked right
the door fa the door that door failed to
lock for employees but now work to
Perfection he had locked himself inside
how many how how much do you think like
in that moment when it locked he thought
I'm someone's [__] now for the next long
period or he thinks I've got my own
house yeah I live at this little city
here also there has to be a handwritten
note under the like list of things to do
when closing up little C says the door
doesn't always work make sure you check
it that's right right because pepperoni
yeah
exactly okay yeah so Dan they probably
it probably almost all the way shut
exactly but didn't quite go all the way
in but he made sure he slammed it shut
of course yeah he cares yeah desperate
to escape he finds Through The Dark dark
nness of pizza's past wow a dimly lit
opportunity Tennesse lit opportunity I
know he wonders ellipses if he can get
past the suspended ceiling tiles he can
access the roof and regain his freedom
it's Freedom all of a sudden this is the
story of I know I'm like this is sha
Shang it started so perfunctory in just
like basic beat reporting and now we're
in the realm of poetry now we're like
the Underground Railroad of sorts he
climbs onto an oven so he can pry the
tiles free he pops up through a hole and
climbing higher he begin love this is
all in present tense like that's it's
very literary this is Pros yeah this is
um what's that move that that short
story from the 80s it's all in in in
third person or second person Bright
Lights big city that's what this is he
climbs the the oven he grabs the
cocaine I am Chad Korn's Anger from
childhood he reaches far and farther
still his weight begins to stress the
tile's failure sensing this he reaches
for a group of wires to help stabilize
his swm always if you are a Florida man
in wet socks
grabes espe you're over the grease of
the thing grab the wires gra a wire this
is the craziest way to tell us what's
happening so to break it down he can't
get back out through the door he climbs
up I'm sorry I don't mean to interrupt
you would you mind not gesturing with
your disgusting thumbs while you tell
this story it's like it's taking me out
of the the literary stylings of Chad
corn I'll just do tour guide
hand
so what we're going to do he climbs up
onto the oven uhhuh tries to get through
the up in the tiles tiles start to give
way he grabs wires grabs wires
surrounded by dis disintegrating tiles
and Loosely bound wires he falls all the
way to the ground he lands on a tumbled
heap of wires broken ceiling tiles and
hurt feelings I did not write this did
say hurt feelings is 100% this person
this is unbelievable with stars circling
his head that that did not star circling
his head like a looney tun cartoon when
little birds chirping with stars
circling his head he gathers his senses
and stands a beautiful woman walks by
his tongue falls out of his mouth like
he says
AA the aroma of a pie in a window sill
like a finger pulls him to towards it
but as he goes to snatch the pie an
anvil seemingly from out of nowhere
falls on his head but then it changes
again the woman walks in the ding of the
Bell can be heard it switches again I
heard her the moment she walked in now
we're at Noir this is actually Noir this
is Florida Noir Florida no Florida Noir
could be the new name of this
podcast Florida Noir that's she walked
in I was smoking meth out of a
light all eggs and
scabs I thought I'd never see those
crazy eyes again I said sit right there
it's true cuz she checked herself into
rehab the next day take a seat in that
Target shopping cart tell I said you can
poop anywhere you like if you're thirsty
there's Cold Mountain Dew in the ice box
she was my sister and my cousin what
okay with star circling his head he
gathers his senses and stands at about
this time the alarm begins to sound he
panics and hurries towards the
drive-through window he pulled the alarm
cord that's right as he makes his way
the phone begins to ring Little Caesar
kind of help you now he's making orders
he's got to get [__] out okay I'm going
to make this but I have to go so if
you're not going to pick it up Ops are
on the way he's on the line it's not hot
and ready yet oh yes I I'm going to have
to write your credit card number down
though this is what makes it a comedy if
he starts filling the orders yes and
feeling like overwhelmed over
why do we not why did we not get all the
parmesan cheese out oh no who could it
be calling at this hour someone should
answer the phone I did not bolster any
of this writing someone should answer
the phone and Korn is that someone for
reason only corn knows Chad corn can I
help you Chad corn corn industry former
little former little Chad corn hang on
one second Chad corn hang on one second
this is Chad g go for Chad go for
Chad
hold hold hold go for or he starts
answering like agencies do in town uh I
have Chad corn for you can you hold for
a second that that was the best I I I
will say probably my favorite moment in
Bojack Horsemen the the agent calls
Bojack yes and he said so I have so and
so for you and he said okay I'll take it
he said and then the assistant is like
let me see if I can
get so funny
it's so Dum it is like for who is this
joke for
us let me see if I can get her all right
for reason only corn knows he answers
the phone the conversation would lead to
a level of guilt our burglar had heret
for not
considered oh my God the guilt would
cause him to grab a receipt and leave a
note oh my satisfied our burglar heads
back to the drive-through window at this
point but what has he done he's taken a
brownie and two
a ride UPS he [__] the roof up yeah he
[__] the roof screwed some wires up at
this point he's been in the store long
enough to qualify for employee to
employee for of the month and he dressed
for it he F this person wants out of
their job yeah and let's stop with the
roast jokes Chad Corn's had it hard
enough that's right he finally have you
ever had roasted corn though it's pretty
good it's pretty good yeah I used to
have it in Iowa of course Chad alorn he
finally crawls out of the drive-through
window and into the parking lot Little
Caesar are the parking lot never seen
that in my life well I one only to come
face to face with Deputy Jonathan Hill
according to him we now have six
paragraphs about Jonathan Hill born in
1965 mountain of a man Hill stood before
this person this was the final battle
between Hill and corn the hill corn
fight Deputy Jonathan Hill his his
things don't amount to a hill corn and
the green uniform of
Justice in Florida these cops have green
they are green Florida struggling to
explain his appearance he is placed
under arrest Korn is charged with
burglary exceeding $11,000 in Damages
and peti theft is it petite P TI T
petiti theft wow so this that's what the
French call that when you almost have an
orgasm so this th this reporter is
writing this as if he or she is
witnessing it in
process at one point we are in process
there's multiple different first person
are eyes of the story This is the real
rash mon we will get out of here on this
how old is Chad Korn oh here's what you
know it's midm morning which I can only
assume they mean noon to noon so 6:00
a.m. yeah definitely like cuz somebody's
at a Little Caesars by 10 5 a.m. I think
it's still dark out but we're trying to
figure out the age what I'm saying so
I'm trying to give us context of what we
know about this guy it's a midm morning
right which means it was his night could
be three could be four could be five
socks and boxers wanted an apron wanted
two bottles of water and boxers could be
the name possibly we needed hydrate true
I think you should honestly and this is
a real pitch I think you should rename
the podcast Chad corn Chad corn or theft
either way cornon the corn Chronicles
the corn Chronicles of Florida noad Corn
and he don't care okay 52 years old 52
took a brownie an apron took a ride
upstairs called out of a drive-through
window he is phone left a note 31 you
don't leave a note if you're 46
46 a a younger man would have nimbly
found a way through the roof to end
Story one before Jason Takes Over story
two plus we hear plugs from me and from
Ria about his amazing book I will tell
you this Chad Korn
is 35 years old over here can't have a b
he's literally in the area where he
shouldn't have a baby but could be
president yeah he could be president he
might be president honestly the way
things are going could be president
wouldn't be the worst option Chad corn
running for president marao 2 is now
just a Little Caesar's in madon Florida
he's holding Court down there he's got
documents under the wires all right scar
Lago is coming up after the break and we
find out about Mosa's new book that you
must pick up I'm very excited to read
this uh we back with more dumb people
town with mosha Casher right after
this around s's people hey guys welcome
back to the show very excited to be here
I hope you did something fun in the
break before we get to talking about
this lovely book right here Daniel I
know you just did pen pals at sketchfest
I know that when we're recording this I
know that was really fun but you got
stuff on the horiz movies out wine club
is out right now heard the screening was
amazing and I'm sorry we were out of
town to see it sorry I wasn't invited
thought of I'm sorry you weren't invited
or thought of either you can watch it
now too because where can people watch
it wherever you stream anything you want
to rent it's available awesome uh it's
absolutely great um Steve Little's in it
Taylor Ortega is in it a whole bunch of
really good people Dan is the lead
[__] the lead I am I am it's a
it's a these people alope and then go to
a winery and find out it's a cult run by
a former Child CV star who's played by
Steve little hilarious wonderful super
fun uh go to Daniel van kirk.com too you
can just uh click a l right there you
can also see all of my dates I will be
the first week I think 8th 9th I'm in DC
and I have other dates coming out as
well in May I'll be in Wisconsin and my
special rose gold drops on April 17th so
go to Daniel van.com we will make a nice
push for that uh I'm looking at this
gorgeous book mosha cash I love the
cover subculture vulture great name for
the the book what can people expect with
this it's out where can they get it
taught to us uh it is I'm super proud of
it it's like the thing that I sold over
the pandemic that
alive M it's myo actually but kind of a
concept memo it's like a trip through
the six subcultures that have created
the DNA of my life so those are uh
Alcoholics Anonymous I got sober when I
was 15 years old I've been sober ever
since but iations slowly make a my way
out of know you're one of the few at
Burning Man that that goes completely
sober I'm the designated Art Car Driver
God bless you manic Judaism and Judaism
my father was a born again hassid my par
my parents split he became uh immersed
in the world of hidic Judaism and I
spent my summer vacations cosplaying as
an extra from Fiddler on the Roof while
being a Oakland Public School secular
kid the rest of and building a tunnel
under the city for what an interesting
Dynamic it was quite a dynamic to put
that cloak on and then not even put it
on but then also take it off oh it was
wild I mean it was I would literally get
picked up at the airport driven to the
hidic Jewish Barber Shop the barber
would kind of grunt at me and try to
turn my California bull cut into like a
old world tradition like Sid locky
haircut put slacks on in aak and I would
go into the old country where all the
kids spoke yish as a first language
first language the dodgeball games in
Seagate were the ultra Orthodox Kids
versus the actually religious kids I
mean it was that Stark we were the
non-jew they called us [__] we were
wearing yamakas and they would scream
[__] at us can I ask you a question which
version of you felt more you as you were
finding your identity when did you was
it in California or did you feel like
you did I guess you said that one felt
like cosplay so you so so maybe you
answer your question I apologize no that
I would say that the the J the Judaism
stuff and the deaf well that's the world
three deafness and sign language
interpreting my family all of my family
my father my mother my cousins my
brothers all de we had two really close
friends growing up the mullman uh Randy
and and Scott mullman who we played
sports with whose parents were both both
parents deaf I love these people so much
they came to our game so like we had a
deep window into that world like we knew
someone who grew up with two parents who
were deaf and so and we were close with
these people so like both both of the
kids were they red lips though it's such
a weird thing to be born into a deaf uh
family because you are simultaneously a
member of the culture and a member of
the uh opposition party it's like being
born white in wakanda and you're you
you're a citizen of wakanda but you also
represent the enemy so all of those
swirling yeah both in both even those
two out of those six you are straddling
Two Worlds I was a straddler and uh and
I and I I that's probably why I ended up
going to AA eventually because the truth
is what I found the first time I got
high when I was 12 years old was that
all that weird difference that I felt
that made me feel like a sore thumb oh
I'm so sorry to say sore
thumb stuck out like two U it all went
away but it went away so starkly and so
hard that by the time I was 15 I'd been
in and out of rehab three times I've
been in mental institutions arrested
more times than I could count flunk 9th
grade three times was assailed with
Oppositional Defiant Disorder diagnosis
add conduct disorder depression learning
disabilities all that stuff and I hit
rock bottom and at 15 which is a strange
thing to do my is 15 my son is 15 and
he's at rock bottom well he started he
was born at Rock Bottom he goes daddy
he's the ban of and he said his parents
are about DF well actually I don't know
if you know this but I'm about to do a
very bad job
my from my early years of Comedy this
let let's he it well my mom has always
loved and supported my dream of being a
comedian and so much so that she was
really supportive even though she could
never hear my comedy she would come to
some of my early shows and she would
bring like jars of homemade preserves
and jellies and she would sell them
outside of the club to like support me
going on the road and um I see the weird
you do see where this is going this is
weird that you're able to actually track
this I see it well the thing thing about
it is at a certain point her thing The
Preserve she was selling they they took
on a life of their own and they actually
got I would say more famous than even me
comedy you guys familiar with heard they
were sold at the Apollo that's right you
guys know about de Comedy Jam
right I've heard
it you walked so far around the C what
was so cool is that your mom wasn't the
only person who uh experienced total
silence while you were doing your crowds
did as well folks people going to kill
us if you don't say what are the other
ones okay so can I guess can I guess
guess stand up so you had hidic or
Judaism uh a AAA a AA Judaism uh music
definitely music is in there well Raves
when I when I was about 9 months sober I
realized I was 15 I had the rest of my
life in front of me and I wanted to like
find a way to have a teenage fun and I
randomly bought a ticket to a rave and I
walked into this Warehouse in Oakland by
myself and sober like 9 months 16 years
old and had as close to a Jesus in the
desert moment as you can have wasn't
that beautiful that you realized that
you didn't need the drugs and the
alcohol to have a like you just probably
like like I just opened a door and
unlocked a whole new thing doors are the
in some ways the theme of the book this
it's it it is about what I I make this
analogy to like the books I liked
reading when I was a kid were like
Narnia and uh and um uh um you know well
Harry Potter is one I wasn't a thing
that opens up to another world exactly
you're a weak loser who thinks nobody
loves you and you're powerless and just
nothing something's fundamentally wrong
with you and somay one day somebody
opens up a door and you walk through it
and you go not only am I in a new
universe but I am I have
superpowers the hero King here so okay
so so that so Rave uh comedy definitely
standup comedy and the world of standup
comedy and is Burning Man the other one
well at about a year into going to Raves
I heard there was a rave in the desert
this is 1996 and I that was enough to
get me to jump into a car and drive 6
hours in the middle of nowh to something
I did not know what I was doing H or
where I was going and I got there in '96
16 years old and I stepped out of my car
and I go I don't know what this is but
this is not a rave and this is when
burningman was was what it was supposed
to early days of what it is on the it
was it was in Black Rock City but it was
dangerous two people died there was a
guy that was dead before I got there
there were drive by shooting ranges
people were getting run over in their
cars I was 16 and my mind was absolutely
bone and last year was 20 my 24th time
going I worked at Burning Man for 15
years I I have seen how the Psychedelic
sausage is stuffed I've seen it change
from as they say a place where uh where
PE weird people used to go to feel
normal to a place where normal people go
to feel weird that's right and and now I
am uh and now I am 44 years old old and
looking back on all of these worlds and
in each of these segments I tell a
history it's not just my story it's the
the story of the of this the the world
so it's it's one part history one part
comedy one part Memoir and I'm very
proud of it so let me ask you two
questions about it one people should buy
the book just because books are
important and you're supporting one of
our friends who is a phenomenal writer
and comedian two if someone is like I
have a hard time reading I don't have
time in my life I I don't know how to do
it they should get the audio book cuz
I'm assuming you read it you did the
audio actually I'm gonna hook your
listeners up and say I'm GNA read from
page one the entire book on this episode
of sounds great and you don't even have
to buy the I want you to buy it or buy
the audio bu you read the audio book The
a I want you to do one of the two this
is this is your way to support comedians
Like Comics like us are creating
material Dan special something like this
this is how you support comedians like
us and this is how we get to do more
things like that I'm just excited if I
didn't know you I would want to read
this tour of it I am doing a tour I
leave on on the 30th I'll be in Austin
and then DC and then New York San
Francisco Portland and Los Angeles
everything is on my website Mosher dcom
m o h e go watch and read and then buy
the book when he comes get I will say
this I the the book is funny and the
book is super interesting and
informative but it's also um really
emotional and I put a lot of myself into
it and it's really a story about looking
back and realizing that only in
hindsight can you see like the sort of
glowing path of Destiny and maybe
Destiny is random and a [__] concept
or maybe it's actually like a a my a
mystical concept but looking back and
realizing that I was always sort of
headed here I was always headed to dumb
people Town yes you were yes you were if
I hadn't gone through all these
iterations I wouldn't have met my wife I
wouldn't have started comedy I wouldn't
have my career I wouldn't have we saw
that happen we watched that whole thing
happen as friends of both of you guys oh
my God this is like I cannot wait to
read this subculture vulture pick it up
listen to the Audi book go see on live
on the tour mos.com and you can like see
if he's coming to a city near you go see
him and go up and say hey I heard you on
dumb people town I love that you're here
and this is it J all right I got another
person who was destined to be in dumb
people let here sent in by Jake grony at
Jake grony thanks Jake uh woman in pink
dress steals tractor Florida cops say
and then it got weird what so all right
sure she's kind of a Princess Peach
Mario Kart situation or Barbie just
continued Barbie extended why not Barbie
the farmer Farmer Barbie farmerie farie
farmer barbie.com uh a woman wearing a
pink dress is accused of carrying out a
series of odd thefts in a rural Florida
Community one of which one of which
involved riding off on someone's and
we'll do a guessing game right now John
Deere tractor how much was this tractor
is it worth
yeah last you go you think you know well
I have a general idea of the cost of I'm
going to go 12K 12K oh I'm going to say
like
$38,000
$250,000 no really it's like that I'm
going to I'm I'm it depends on the
tractor $1 $1 okay get your answers in
this John Deere tractor cost
$10,000 you close the damn according to
S like a fire truck dude no fire trucks
are a million dollars the cost of like
you guys know what a combine is yeah
it's a grindy thing it's the kind of
thing
long AR you would run up and put both
THB Harvest me Harvest me Chad corn Chad
corn Chad corn
Chad the price on those is like crazy I
think like 600,000 I mean they're in I
mean they make your life easy you have
to combine incomes in order
to it's all in the book all right uh why
this one one of the tractor unclear but
detectives note that it was not the
strangest thing taken during the Spree
bed sheets hm bed sheets hey while
you're out hey man it's hard to find a
good fitted sheeton and man blue jeans
baby is she from Russia toiletries sure
toilet that makes sense single used
apron from a local wait a minute Chad
three Q-tips all right camouflage
waiting
boots those are just shoes in Florida to
be fair that could be like I'm going out
to the club tonight you wearing your
waiting boots you go to a Foot Locker in
Florida it's just all hip waiting boots
every year at this point only for myself
when I am up at my family's little cabin
in Wisconsin it is quite popular for men
and women to wear camo everywhere they
go everywhere they go they want to blend
in there's just at some point in the
night where I'm like I all you I all
these floating heads like I try to like
give them [__] about wearing camo and no
one ever thinks it's funny D you know
what you need to start saying is when
you see people thank you for your
service in Desert Storm I appreciate
everything you did was it Desert Shield
was Shield not storm okay thank you uh
bed sheets blue jeans toiletries
camouflage weding boot several packages
of froz are you reading We Didn't Start
the
Fire C waiting boots and several
packages of Frozen venison wait is that
real yeah several packages of Frozen
venis that's a good poll actually such a
good lean you need to wrap it in the
sheets and a bottle of wine and a bottle
of wine bottle of wait there's a sheet
there's a sheet there's a meal so in
case there's a h couple needs to have
sex there's the sheet wait a second did
you just say a case a hidic couple needs
to have sex through a sheet yes in my
book sorry to
derail book the show's called derail
town in my book subculture vulture I
deal with the nasty uh rumor that that
is so pervasive in the Jewish world that
some Jews believe it about hidic Jews
which is this rumor that we have sex
through a sheet and it is not true why
would it be true why would they do such
a thing but here is the origin of that
rumor let's he it in ancient times no in
in in pre-war Europe Jews and non-jews
would live in a village together but
this is honestly which war the first or
second let's say preor War I all the
time 1800 wherever we are we're in we're
in in the pale of settlement Jews and
non-jews are kind of living in villages
side by side they don't have dryers and
they do it old school style their
laundry they will hang it from a line in
the yard and the non-jewish CH and Jews
wear this thing called a a Talis or but
it's called a Titi which is a It's Like
a Prayer guard with a a hole for your
head you've seen these right it almost
looks like a penny if you're playing
pickup basketball right A A Penny they
call those pennies you put them over
your head exactly that's right so it's
got a hole for your head you put it over
your head so they would La their their
little prayer garment they would put it
on their laundry line and little
non-jewish children would walk by the
yard of the Jewish families and see
hanging from the laundry line a big
Square sheet with a hole in the middle
and think the only logical thing you
think when you see a square cloth they
go somebody's [__] through that pie
got to be and it became such a pervasive
myth that Jew believe it about
themselves said it today people say it
to me when I say my family was acidic
they go oh they fck did you know that I
go yeah tell me about it that's why my
dad's not allowed within 70 ft of a Bed
Bath and Beyond that's right that's the
Beyond before yes that's the joke before
he got there it was just called bed and
bath what uh what culture were you
living in when you lost your virginity
oh I lost my virginity not in Seagate I
lost my virginity in Oakland okay I
assumed but it would be wild if it was I
did it through a
dag Oak Town Oak Town Oak Town represent
all right the woman is also accused of
sleeping in one of of the victim's bed
is she a modern-day goldilock she is
this is it Pinky loocks it is a fun
concept to think of Goldilocks is just
really really methed out that's our bit
that's we're doing each other's bit
psychically today we have our bit the
premise of our bid is that fairy tales
read like police blots in the State of
Florida funny that's great if you were
to put the phrase a Florida man or a
Florida woman in front of plot of a
fairy tale totally works Florida woman
breaks into a house eats their food
breaks a chair is found passed out in
the kids bed that's incredible are you
guys going to do that or can I do
it I oh I can do it Daniel we can stop
giving permission that's awesome all
right that's cool come see me on my book
tour I'm all this stuff hang on AE uh
we're performing at the same Club where
Carlos men is performing uh weeks before
I think he might take the bit okay at
last count the suspect was facing this
is exhausting the things she the amount
the amount of just carry around I mean I
know it's probably drug fueled but I
always get weird when we have a story
where someone makes me feel bad about
what I've gotten done in a day yeah I
can do one podcast woman does more she's
multitasking she's on the lamb she's got
an entire wardrobe and a meal and a meal
with
L took time to rest I mean uh she's
facing what how many misdemeanors and
how many felonies with more possible oh
my God how many misdemeanors misdemeanor
15 I was going to go 16 I'll go 16 16
how many felonies I'll go nine on the
misdemeanors I'll go 11 felonies I'm
going to go two felonies I'm going to go
20 felonies this is what is shocking
Randy you're on the right track three
misdemeanors and a whopping 35 felonies
I mean come on why it shouldn't be any
it should just be your released go to
rehab 35 felonies for taking a tractor
and some jeans so someone who's taking
jeans and Venice and stuff like that I
think the cops should be like let's just
release her and see what she does next
let's release her with
to be fair unless you haven't gotten to
it she hasn't done anything violent
she's hurt hurt any other person she's
this is sort of like to me it should be
one felony if you're going to ring her
up tell that to the deer
community criminal my they're like
that's my uncle in there they were cut
up when I got here man your uncle's in
the jeans uh investigators say crimes
occurred May 6th in the Kathleen area
about 30 Mi Northeast of Tampa a
neighbor was the first to report
something suspicious after seeing a
female in a pink dress driving a tractor
in the area why they keep bringing up
the pink because you just you don't
imagine a one and this is maybe our
problem we need to break through the
stereotype a woman in a pink dress
driving a tractor someone's like my that
my receptors are up she's probably not
doing work are we all picturing a maxi
what do you mean like a a long dress
long dress call Max Max dress
interesting a dress that looks like a
double brasted oversized jacket jacket
I'm thinking of almost a night gown sure
like a like a a sheer all near near
night but none of us are going like
shimmery cocktail no no not fancy that
would be nice on the way to marago typ
of situation I like the idea I like the
idea that they reported some the
neighbor reported something suspicious I
would like to be on that 911 call like I
see something suspicious what is it
again a 6'2 blonde woman in a pink dress
on a tractor with a venison sir dress
say no more we're on our way woman in
just called back
women women on pink dress on tractor
which one all right it's not often you
see a woman stealing a John Deere
tractor while wearing a pink dress the
Sheriff's Office wrode on Facebook of
course obviously they're going to like
all the material why do these police
departments do this like social media
trolling my favorite is when they go you
can't make this stuff up and it's like
you can make it up or they're like
you'll never believe it I go I will you
just said it happen you can't make this
up and you also can't plant evidence you
did that though like you can't make this
up like have you never seen the movie
The Cell you can make it up dude uh no
you know what's crazy is like I wonder
if they check their Facebook post and be
like how many how many likes many lik
sure they do a lot of likes on and I
think it's cuz you said you can't make
this up uh they found the okay A Farm
property manager managed to detain the
suspect when the tractor a nice big John
Deere model not a farmer 6120r stalled
the sheriff's office said then deputies
arrived and arrested her they found the
woman had a knife with a how many inch
blade on it she lives in Florida she
hasn't tried to use the knife is allor
she's done and nobody had used her knife
to blank that's just a gator gutter
right there that ain't nothing Gat 15in
blade I'm going to go seven nine 5 in
Blade along with that's good long longy
too she had the 5 in Blade along with
other people's credit debit cards social
security cards a driver's license got
everything and a dental plan card okay
she deserves the 35 felonies that's meth
right meth is like I need to fix these
damn te good for her though yeah she's
trying to get her life together
proactive thank you thank the suspect
became I irate when deputies attempted
to pull her uh to put her in a patrol
car the sheriff's office said she kicked
and cursed at deputies and even made a
death threat or two to them yeah this is
what happens when you run a cult but no
one joins
right you're your own culture yeah
you're everything all right charges in
the case include grand theft of course
burglary of
dwelling unoccupied dwelling so no one's
wearing a wearing a pink dress dress on
pink dress being a lady on a John Deere
tractor possession of a concealed weapon
it's not Jane
deer and batter this is what happens
when drag queens start reading stories
to your kids soon you got a lady on a
pink dress on a John Deere tractor
you're joking but that's what is it it's
not a pride tractor there you go that's
the story there you oh my gosh good Lord
good Lord wait do you do you guys even
like it's not even funny anymore when it
says Florida at the beginning of the
we're like we're in for it we're in for
it it is it's just standing it doesn't
even stick out I'm a gigantic apologist
for Florida I love Florida I think it's
cool I mean listen politic you hang in
Florida I just think it's a beautiful
state I so I've been to Western Florida
and my wife's uh stepfather and mom
lived in santelle and it was like the mo
it was like it's one of my favorite
places to goor gorgeous St Pete Miami I
mean I love to go to Miami cities I love
to go to Miami I do cocaine for week
right and I just hang on a second You're
Sober Miami's home base baby I'm fine
guess what else I'm not in Miami mared
and straight all right guys right back
we have one more segment and this is
just again it's like everybody let's
check the F let's double check things
before we assume things okay that's what
this story is about we'll tell you what
we have going on it's DB people tell
most sh Casher I'm holding the book
subculture vulture pick it up now pick
it up in the break or get the audio book
we'll be right
[Music]
back I don't know about you guys but
like I just went through all the things
that I have subscriptions for and I'm
like why do I have a subscript there at
least five you don't why am I paying
money for this did it I did it with
rocket money they they helped me because
I had tried to cancel this golf
subscription that I had to this golf
service that was giving me it was so
hard to get to them and have them
respond to me in order to cancel the
subscription Rock and money did it they
just handle it for you it saves you time
it saves you money look we subscribe to
things and we forget about them and then
you know we want to clean things up this
is how you can clean up your life and
and help yourself save some money money
that's flying out the door you don't
even realize rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions right period we
just talked about they monitor your
spending and it helps lower your bills
doesn't this all sound awesome brilliant
uh when you do it you can see all your
subscriptions in one place that's what I
love if I see something that I want I
just cancel with a tap that's what Jason
just said I never have to get on the
phone with customer service rockout
money has over 5 million users and has
helped save its members an average of
$720 a year with over 500 million in
cancelled subscriptions so here's what
I'm going to say I'm going to say stop
wasting money on things you don't use
right cancel your unwanted subscriptions
by doing one thing go to Rocket
money.com DPT it lets them know that we
sent you there that's rocket money.com
DPT one more time rocket
money.com
[Music]
DPT hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get into it uh I think I'm
assuming this one is going to drop soon
because this is out we want to you know
get this going we're going to be in
Denver uh at the great comedy bks God
bless comedy work the South Club we were
there there last time I love the South
Club it's like a beautiful theater oh
the bigger one landar one first that
story is in the book first Club I ever
headlined wow they call I remember my
agent called me and said uh they uh the
Denver Comedy Works wants you and I go
great who am I opening for and he goes
they want you to headline and I go what
oh yeah he's said do you have 45 minutes
I go of course yes and then he got off
the phone like I need 35 more minutes I
told every joke I'd ever written
including Open Mic jokes and I remember
the clock on the stage counted down from
45 and I mean the last word of the last
joke it was like 45 minutes exactly good
night
everybody you by the way you were
performing at Comedy Works we had not
gotten in there this is like maybe 12 13
years ago and we were in town doing in
town doing another show and then we came
over at the end and you let us come up
after you finished which is like such a
weird thing to come up after the
headliner is done but you allowed us to
do it and we had a great set and then
they booked us so oh that's why that's
how you got in I think that was I mean
you guys are huge and we know that would
have gotten in eventually but I will
take credit for this you take credit for
that so we'll be there uh the 1 through
the 3rd of February we want to sell
those shows out I love that then we're
back to the first club we ever worked
the very first Club Markley's Comedy
Castle the first weekend first thing gig
we ever got paid at a comedy club that's
one that's in the first weekend in uh
Roy Ro migan is that a great place big
there's a guy who every time I post a
gig I feel so bad he goes please come to
Mark Ridley's Comedy Castle we'll tell
you how it is I mean he's just a fan and
he's just obsess part of Detroit it's in
a cool part of Detroit and we've
recently just you know after doing a
bunch of stuff for University of
Michigan I think we'll have some people
who might come I hope so so anyway
that's very excited about that and then
Minneapolis AC me at the beginning of uh
April and then at the end of April we're
doing uh oh no and in May we're going to
be in Salt Lake City doing Wise Guys all
right super.com can I get into this
please let's do this right now okay this
is sent in by Professor deer at an
McCarthy story comes from uh September
we're jumping all over the place here we
go you ready for the headline classic
McCarthyism police right police called
to yoga class mistaken for Mass killing
whoa oh so cor pose turned into a whole
new meeting oh I like this a yoga class
was cut short after a member of the
public called the police to report a
mass killing after seeing several people
lying on the Flor now I agree you
someone reports a mass killing the
police can't just be like nah whatever
what are they wearing is it a pink dress
what's so someone like walks out of a
Michaels with her bags goes past a yoga
place a bun people it's like oh my God
911 guys we have she probably bangs
right and then the teacher is also there
it's like ignore all IGN all the outside
sound this is what you call news brain
you know that's a person that's been
watching CNN 24/7 for like seven days
and just knows it's something horrible
every True Crime documentary ever wait
so ran you got to tell your thing about
your yoga class you were h yoga class so
when I first started doing it I uh I
misheard did I say this on this podcast
I misheard what the person said so there
she was naming all the poses in Sanskrit
and one of them was called Janu shirasa
but I heard Johnny shirasa and to me
that was the funniest thing ever so I'm
doing it I'm thinking of like Johnny
shirasa is what the
guys on The Sopranos called the one guy
who did yoga once he walks over like hey
a regular Johnny [__] sheras over
here won't you put your head between
your balls why you bend over and suck my
dick I'll put you in corse post anyway
so I I'm now doing this bit for everyone
in the class you're talking you and
start doing stand
up after the class where everyone's
sweaty and hanging out and I'm like yeah
regular Journey [__] I'm loud and I'm
like doing this like new to the yoga
scene I know my voice down and the
teacher who has no sense of humor walks
just walks right out here's the whole
thing I'm saying it's Janu and walked
right back in the room and I was like
all right regular Johnny [__] over
here participants in the class which was
being held at the Seascape Cafe is that
where you were a acidic Jew in Seascape
seate very similar okay at the seate now
Seagate is part of the Church of
Scientology that well I will say the
yoga scene in seate is lacking it's a
bit lacking see the
three TV shows that I will that I think
are exactly the same Farscape
Seagate and there's one other one
Stargate Stargate Stargate Stargate
Seascape and fargate anyway our
participants in the class are being held
there inside the North Sea observatory
in Chapel St Leonard's skegness
Lincolnshire were in the mid Bri just
love to name things oh this is England
we're in the midst of meditation when
officers turned up Wednesday night in a
Facebook post God damn you the cafe said
oh the cafe is posting this on Facebook
we are not dead we are alive stop doing
the Johnny Shas a bit please someone had
reported a mass killing after seeing
people on the floor inside the I heard
somebody at your yoga studio reported a
mass killing
after hey hey it's a Johnny
Bo well side five between je a side five
in a long time I took
it how you doing in in a comes back the
next week remember me it's Johnny SAS
like not into it dude no no we said no
we said dog so down about nobody says no
to Johnny Shas hey look who's here I
make him an anyone heard the mass of
police sirens you can't use mass of
police sirens when describing a mass
killing you're not allowed to use the
word mass swear to me it's
murder Mass killing in Chapel St
Leonard's at what time what time in the
afternoon 3 o00 in the afternoon the
sirens if everyone's dead just kind of
slowly go over there and be like knock
too late anyway the mirror up and then
see uh you say 3: you say 9:00 a.m.
10:30 a.m. get your answers
1057 this thing took place at 9:30 p.m.
last night please be reassured they were
on their way to the observatory after
someone reported a mass killing in our
building having seen several people
laying on the floor which actually
turned out to be a Lo yoga class in
meditation this person just saw a
document about Jon was like everyone Dr
the Kool-Aid and that's the end it's
news brain y'all can we stop using we
drank the Kool-Aid as like a thing about
like yeah we really drank the Kool-Aid
about that uh in the corporate office
like Dr the Koolaid on that memo you all
everyone died women and children you
forced your children to you watch your
children good uh so uh the face we are
not part of any mad cult or crazy clubs
they said all in all the situation
turned out positive and we are of course
grateful grateful to Who Who Are You
grateful to grateful that nobody's not
dead look the North Sea Observatory has
a large triangular windows that face the
sea a Facebook post on the caf's page
say the venue holds new moon yoga
classes on Wednesdays from 7:30 to 9:00
you know they were like guys you can
sign up now you know they use it as a
way to promote it uh where you can feel
uh called to Deep dive into our lunar
cycle now it's like that's having sex on
the period a deep dive into the lunar
cycle is pictures in the post the ti is
high call that the strawberry
dip the little di more like the big dier
a little dier uh Lincoln share police
confirmed uh to the PA news agency that
the call was made at 8:56 with good
intentions a spokes uh so it wasn't like
a hey you should prank part it feels
like you do find them just the like some
sort like a $50 they have to now then
say what you got to check that out after
you see that
do
through called the police this is the
thing that like how about a how about a
knock on the window hey you guys all
dead no okay okay someone just make a
someone fart just do anything to just
make a noise and you you do Cobra and
get up and look at her and go I got a
bit I could
do uh look at me I'm a
snake this the only Cobra I don't pay
for okay all right call my favorite
Cobra was
Stallone what's the coopay on this [__]
all right call was made following
concerns for the occupant of the North
Sea Observatory they said officers
attended were happy report everyone was
safe and well to me I would have loved
if the officers all laid down and took a
picture with them as well but apparently
they did not no they did not that's it
just a stupid check knock twice check
twice before you do the thing that is
measure twice cut once [__] are
you dead are you dead keep on stretching
continue are you a tree oh that's just
tree pose okay good regular [__] tree
pose the book The the book subculture
vulture you like the mafia like see
there is crime in this book I love how
there's your crime you commited crime
well when I got into the Rave thing I
very quickly started throwing my own
parties DJing and then eventually I
became maybe the world's only uh Teenage
clean and sober ecstasy dealer hey now
wow and I spent that was how I made my
living is selling ecstasy pills for a
few you never made as much money in your
life that was oh the good old days well
you were driving a nice car at that
point well you know I they called me uh
and they said they want you to sell
drugs and I said really for who and they
said no they want you to headline can
you do it for 45 minutes I only have do
you have 45 ex bills and I was like yes
I do just like I just got 45 uh pick it
up love you MOS thanks for coming on
this is so great and uh to all our fans
oh [__] we got to get back to work
sck around make sound there's
[Music]
to